Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast der ESA und des DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich freue mich, alle hier zur 11. Ausgabe dieser Gesprächsserie zu begrüßen, in der es beim letzten Mal um Raumstationen ging und wir eigentlich nach viel Vorbereitung überhaupt das allererste Mal das Thema Astronautentum berührt haben. Ja, aber wir werden diesem Thema jetzt ein wenig treu bleiben in dieser Ausgabe, wie auch in der nächsten. Da könnt ihr euch schon mal auf ein ganz spezielles Thema freuen. Heute allerdings geht es um die Ausbildung von Astronauten und welche Wege diese bestreiten müssen, um überhaupt erstmal den Weg ins All zu finden. Und ich freue mich besonders auf meinen heutigen Gast, Samantha Christopheretti. Ja, du bist, weiß nicht, sagt man schon, bist du schon Astronautin?
Ja, also mit meinen Kollegen, die mit mir 2009 ausgewählt wurden, haben wir ja die Grundausbildung hier im Europäischen Astronautenzentrum in Köln im November im letzten Jahr fertig gemacht, also absolviert. Und dadurch sind wir dann offiziell Astronauten der ESA.
Aha, okay, super. Das heißt, man muss gar nicht erst im All gewesen sein.
Nein, also natürlich freuen wir uns alle darauf, wirklich ins All zu kommen, aber wir können uns offiziell Astronauten nennen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie bist du denn zu diesem Thema überhaupt gekommen? Bist du auch so, wie so viele immer so beseelt schon von Kindheit an mit dem Blick in den Sternen?
Eigentlich schon, ja. Wie die Massenastronauten habe ich eigentlich schon von Kindheit her davon geträumt, Astronautin zu werden, in den Saal zu fliegen. Ich sage immer, ich bin nicht diejenige, die den Weltraum gewählt hat, sondern der Weltraum hat mich gewählt. Ich war einfach so klein, dass ich wahrscheinlich keine bewussten Entscheidungen noch treffen konnte, aber ich habe mich einfach so spontan dafür begeistert. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe sehr viel Science-Fiction gelesen. Ich hatte ganz gute Lehrer in der Schule, die schon damals in der vierten, fünften Klasse angefangen haben, von Sternen zu erzählen, von Planeten, vom Sonnensystem. Ich habe das einfach so faszinierend gefunden. Ich habe Bücher von meinen Eltern von der Uni genommen, fast geheim, und dann müssen weiter gelesen, also wahrscheinlich nicht viel davon verstanden, aber trotzdem fand ich es einfach faszinierend. Und dann habe ich einfach das Glück gehabt, dass mit dem Erwachsenwerden langsam meine Leidenschaften dann in der Technik, in der Wissenschaft und dann im Fliegen sich entwickelt haben. Und das sind natürlich Wege, die es dann einfacher machen, sich dann vorstellen zu können, dann wirklich Astronautin zu werden.
Hm, Science Fiction, was hat dich denn da besonders berührt? Meistens sind es dann doch schon so zwei, drei Bücher, die so einen besonderen Eindruck hinterlassen, oder?
Also sicherlich habe ich sehr viel Asimov gelesen und dann habe ich mich sehr viel für die ganze Star Trek-Welt begeistert. Da habe ich damals wirklich alles Mögliche gesehen und gelesen und ich war so eine richtige Trekkie, wie man so sagt.
Auch so auf Conventions und so? Du bist aus Italien, muss man dazu sagen. Das heißt, da gab es diese ganze erste Prägung, da bist du auch zum Fliegen gekommen?
Ja, ganz genau. Also mein Weg ist ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, untypisch. Ich habe zwischendurch mal meine Meinung geändert, sagen wir mal. Und zwar, ich habe zuerst ein Studium in der Ingenieurwissenschaft absolviert. Und zwar in Deutschland, in München. Ich habe da Maschinenbau studiert mit Vertiefung in der Luft- und Raumfahrt. Und danach ist es, oder in der Zwischenzeit ist es in Italien möglich geworden, auch für Frauen beim Militär zu dienen. Und ich habe dann einfach so versucht, in die Luftwaffe zu kommen als Pilotenanwärterin. Es hat geklappt. Ich bin in der Luftwaffenakademie in Italien aufgenommen worden. Das heißt, ich bin zurück nach Italien gegangen, war vier Jahre in der Akademie und dann bin ich zu Militärpiloten ausgebildet worden. Und in 2009 war ich, sagen wir, am Anfang meiner eigentlichen Karriere. Ich habe damals das IMAX geflogen. Das ist so ein Grund- also Bodenangriff-Flugzeug. IMAX. Und dann kam die Möglichkeit, sich bei der ESA zu bewerben als Astronautin. So eine Möglichkeit kommt natürlich in Europa meistens einmal im Leben.
Was heißt die Möglichkeit, kam? Also, ich meine, bewerben kann man sich doch immer, oder nicht?
Nein, es muss dann eine Wegansicht, also eine Stellenausschreibung da sein. Und das kommt bei uns doch nicht so oft vor. Und da muss man einfach die Gelegenheit gleich ergreifen. Das habe ich natürlich getan. Also da musste ich wirklich keine Sekunden darüber denken. Und dann habe ich dann das Glück gehabt, genommen zu werden.
Aus wie vielen Bewerbern heraus?
Also die Bewerber insgesamt waren 8.500 ungefähr im ganzen Europa. Und am Ende waren wir sechs. Also ich habe natürlich noch fünf tolle Kollegen. Also der Alexander Gerst aus Deutschland, Thomas Pesquet aus Frankreich, Andy Mogensen aus Dänemark, Tim Pieck aus England und noch ein Kollege aus Italien, Luca Parmitano.
Und also von dem Zeitpunkt an, wo die Stelle ausgeschrieben wurde, also Stelle ist ja schon eher, da sind wir glaube ich wirklich bei dem Wort Berufung eigentlich. Also in dem Moment, wo wirklich Astronauten gesucht wurden und bis man dann genommen wurde, was für einen Zeitraum durchläuft das alles?
Also es hat bei uns ein gutes Jahr gedauert eigentlich, weil das Ganze hat am Anfang Mai angefangen, 2008 und in Mai 2009 ist dann die Entscheidung getroffen worden.
Oder haben wir jetzt einfach nur einen Brief hingeschickt und gewartet und dann wurde man genommen oder muss man dann durch verschiedene...
Nee, da muss man sich ein bisschen durchkämpfen durch verschiedene Schritte. Also ganz am Anfang musste man so einen Bewerbungsbogen, sagen wir mal, ausfüllen. Das war sehr, sehr lang und ausführlich. Das war so online im Internet. Da musste man wirklich alles mögliche angeben. Also was jetzt Ausbildung angeht, professionelle Erfahrungen, Sprachkenntnisse, Sporttätigkeiten, die man betreibt, soziale Tätigkeiten, Erfahrungen...
Welche Sprachkenntnisse hattest du zu dem Zeitpunkt schon? Du sprichst ja nun Deutsch extrem gut.
Englisch ist natürlich Pflicht. Italienisch kann ich natürlich, weil ich Italienerin bin. Ich kann auch Französisch und Russisch. Also konnte ich damals schon. Russisch haben inzwischen auch alle Kollegen gelernt.
War das Teil schon der Militärausbildung? Oder ist das jetzt einfach dein persönliches Interesse an Sprachen schon immer gewesen?
Ja, also ich habe mich einfach sehr für Sprachen interessiert. Ich habe in verschiedenen Ländern gewohnt. Also wie gesagt, ich habe in Deutschland studiert und zwischendurch auch Studienaufenthalte in Frankreich und Russland gemacht. Aber schon von der Schule her, ich habe so eine Sprachengymnasium besucht. Das hilft natürlich auch. Genau und dann hat man ein bisschen was dazu schreiben können über die eigene Motivation, die eigenen Vorstellungen über Astronautenberuf.
Du hast da reingeschrieben, ich habe immer Asimov gelesen. Ich sage jetzt unbedingt ihn.
Natürlich habe ich versucht, so professionell zu wirken. Nein, also ich glaube, man muss einfach ehrlich sein. Bei solchen Sachen muss man einfach mit dem Herzen ehrlich sein. Das ist sowohl der richtige Weg als auch der beste Weg, glaube ich, die Leute gut anzusprechen. Dadurch sind von 8.500 Bewerbungen ungefähr 1.000 Kandidaten ausgewählt worden für weitere Tests. Dann sind wir in kleinen Gruppen von, glaube ich, 20 Leuten für einen Tag nach Hamburg eingeladen worden. Wir haben computergestützte, psychokognitive Eignungstests gemacht, ähnlich zu denen, die auch Piloten von Lufthansa machen. Da will man Sachen messen wie Kurzeit-Getechnik sowohl visuell als auch akustisch, Koordination, dreidimensionales Vorstellungsvermögen, auch ein bisschen Fachkenntnis, aber sehr Grundwissen im Bereich Physik, Mechanik, Mathematik, Englisch-Kenten, natürlich. Und es gab auch so Tests um die Koordination, also Augen-, Handkoordination und die Fähigkeit.
Kannst du mal ein Beispiel geben, wie so ein Test so ist, ja so Koordination, akustisches, freundliches Denken etc.?
Also zum Beispiel Gedächtnis, da kriegt man einfach so der Reihe nach, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne, es gab so verschiedene geometrische Formen. Ja, die Langzeitgedächtnis. Ja, aber es gab zum Beispiel geometrische Formen, die mit irgendwelchen Zahlen und Buchstabenkombinationen verbunden waren, die wurden für eine Kurzzeit gezeigt und nach einer Minute wurden sie dann nochmal vorgestellt und man musste die richtiger verbinden können. Oder es wurden im Kopfhörer so Reihen von Zahlen einfach aufgezählt, also eins, sieben, sechs, fünf. Und dann irgendwann hat die Stimme aufgehört, man wusste nicht wann, und dann musste man diese Zahlen rückwärts nochmal hinschreiben. Je mehr, desto besser natürlich. Dreidimensionales Vorstellungsvermögen, dann Sachen wie diese Würfel zum Beispiel, wo man irgendwie zeigen muss, wie sie gedreht wurden. Oder Koordination, da gab es noch ein Joystick, so ein bisschen wie ein Videogame. Und man musste so ein bisschen kleine, feine Koordinationsaufgaben einfach am Bildschirm machen. Oder es gab auch einen Tester, das war wirklich ein kleines bisschen darauf basiert, wie jetzt ein Cockpit oder die Instrumente in einem Cockpit ausschauen. Man musste mit dem Joystick gewisse Aufgaben machen. Das war aber für Piloten nicht unbedingt einfacher, weil sich dieses simulierte Flugzeug sich wirklich nicht so benommen hat, wie normalerweise sich ein Flugzeug benehmen würde. Das heißt, wir als Piloten hatten vielleicht Erwartungen, die dann nicht wirklich getroffen wurden. Das wurde natürlich mit Absicht gemacht, damit Piloten keinen Vorteil haben, sondern wirklich nur Grundfähigkeiten getestet werden. Ja, das war ziemlich anstrengend, muss ich sagen. Wie lange läuft das so? Das war, glaube ich, achtmal eine halbe Stunde, aber wirklich mit voller Konzentration. Die Tests waren wirklich so angelegt, dass es deutlich frustrierend war. Da konnte keiner irgendwie rauskommen und sagen, ich hab das super gemacht, ich hab das gecheckt. Das Niveau war wirklich so hoch, dass jeder irgendwann an die Grenze kam. Teilweise war das auch ein bisschen frustrierend. Wir hatten alle irgendwie den Eindruck, wir haben da wirklich etwas Schlimmes.
Jetzt müssen sich andere Leute holen. Aber es waren nicht alle Tausend auf einmal da. Das ging wahrscheinlich über mehrere Tage und Wochen.
Es ging über mehrere Tage, es ging über ein paar Monate, glaube ich, im Sommer 2009. Und dann sind knapp 200 Leute weitergekommen. Und dann sind wir in Gruppen von sechs Leuten hier nach Köln eingeladen worden.
Wie lange hat das gedauert, bis man das wusste?
Ja, also ich war in einer der ersten Gruppen, die in Hamburg war, Anfang Juli. Und dann die Entscheidung kam im September. Das war vielleicht auch das Schwierigste wirklich an diesem ganzen Bewerbungsverfahren. Weil man musste wirklich dann monatelange warten, zwischendurch. Und das Leben geht ja weiter, die normale Arbeit geht weiter. Man muss ja auch konzentriert sein auf die Arbeit. Und das ist nicht immer einfach. Das erzählen wir immer alle. Also das war wirklich das Schwierigste.
Wird man dann schon angerufen, oder kriegt man dann einen Brief?
Wir haben E-Mails bekommen. Das war alles irgendwie E-Mail-basiert. Und wie gesagt, dann sind wir in Gruppen von sechs Leuten hier nach Köln eingeladen worden. Und es gab noch mal einen Tag, da wurden mehr Sachen getestet, wie man zusammen in einer Gruppe Aufgaben bewältigt. Also es gab zum Beispiel eine Diskussionsrunde. Es gab eine Runde, wo man eine Aufgabe in einer gewissen Zeit lösen musste. Also ein bisschen diese Aufgaben, die entweder keine Lösung haben, oder eine ganz schwierig zu finden, die Lösung.
Das heißt, erst wurde sozusagen grundsätzlich die technische und sprachliche und andere Begabung vorher abgefragt. Dann hat man geschaut, was kann die einzelne Person und ab dem Zeitpunkt geht es vor allem auf die Kollaboration, auf das Zusammenarbeiten.
Ganz genau, weil es ist vor allem in dieser Epoche es ist ganz wichtig, dass Astronauten nicht nur als einzelne Menschen leisten können, sondern auch und vor allem in einem Team gut leisten können, weil was zählt am Ende ist die Leistung des Teams. Das heißt, solche Sachen wie Kommunikation, Teamfähigkeit, soziale Kompetenz, die waren bei unseren Auswahl sehr, sehr wichtig, vielleicht auch wichtiger als in der Vergangenheit. Und genau, es gab dann solche Aufgaben, die dazu darauf ausgerichtet waren und dann sind wir einfach psychologisch untersucht worden von Psychologenpanelen und einzelnen psychologischen Gesprächen. Und dann durften wir nochmal ein paar Monate warten. Und dann sind 45 Leute zu den medizinischen Untersuchungen eingeladen worden. Das hat dann gleich eine ganze Woche gedauert. Da ist wirklich die Gesundheit des jeden gründlich untersucht worden, um da irgendwelche Krankheiten auszuschließen und einfach zu schauen, dass der Körper einfach so richtig funktioniert. Und da sind, glaube ich, 22 Leute weitergekommen. Und dann hatten wir zwei Interviews mit ESA-Management. Zunächst mal mit einem etwas größeren Panel von sechs oder acht ESA-Manager. Einfach ein ganz normales Vorstellungsgespräch, sagen wir mal. Und dann später in einer ganz kleinen Gruppe am Ende mit zehn Leuten, dann mit dem DJ, mit dem Director General von ESA. Und der hat dann die sechs Leute gewählt, die dann...
Also am Schluss macht das der Chef sozusagen?
Genau, am Schluss macht das der Chef.
Was sind denn dann die Kriterien am Ende?
Also das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwer zu sagen. Das ist dann wirklich, glaube ich, eine persönliche Beurteilung vom Chef. Es ist klar, die Leute, die nach einem so langen Verfahren dach hinkommen, sind alle gut genug, sind alle geeignet und gut genug. Und irgendwann muss der Chef einfach so auch ein bisschen gefühlsmäßig den Schaden treffen.
Puh, 8500, 1200, 25, 22, 10 und dann am Schluss 6.
Ganz genau.
Und wie fühlt man sich dann?
Glücklich. Also man privilegiert, sagen wir mal. Ich glaube, wir haben alle das Gefühl, dass wir sehr viel Glück gehabt haben. Weil, wie gesagt...
Es kann von der Kleinigkeit abgehangen haben.
Und wenn wir jetzt den Verfahren nochmal machen würden, genau gleich, dann würden wahrscheinlich sechs ganz verschiedene Leute da sein, die genauso gut geeignet sind. Also wir haben einfach sehr, sehr viel Glück gehabt. Und wir versuchen, das Beste draus zu machen.
Das heißt, dann ging, also wir sind jetzt 2009, 2009 war das alles abgeschlossen, dann ging sozusagen die eigentliche Arbeit schon los. Ging das dann auch gleich sofort los?
Im September, also die AUSO war im Mai, und im September haben wir dann gleich angefangen. Also unser erster Arbeitstag war am 1. September. Und es ist dann wirklich gleich losgegangen mit der Grundausbildung. Es war das erste Mal, dass europäische Astronauten, so als europäisches Team hier in Köln, die Grundausbildung absolviert haben. Also früher sind Astronauten immer zu NASA, nach Houston geschickt worden zur Grundausbildung. Und dieses Mal hat ESA gesagt, wir machen das hier, also wir können das. Und das ging dann 15 Monate lang.
Wir müssen mal kurz erwähnen, was ich nämlich ganz vergessen hatte, zu sagen, wo wir sind, was das im Prinzip schon verraten. Also wir sind in Köln, wir sind hier auf dem Gelände, wo DLR und ESA auch gemeinsam sind und jetzt konkret befinden wir uns hier im ERC, im Europäischen Astronautenzentrum. Hier wird die ganze Ausbildung durchgeführt. Hier werden Astronauten vorbereitet auf Missionen, aber eben auch die Grundausbildung gemacht.
Ganz genau. Also auch bevor wir da waren, wurde natürlich schon hier im ERC Training betrieben. Und zwar ESA ist verantwortlich für das Training aller Astronauten, die zur Raumstation fliegen, für die europäischen Beiträge zur Raumstation. Also hauptsächlich das Columbus-Labor und das ATV-Cargo-Schiff. Das heißt, hier kommen immer wieder Amerikaner, Russen, Japaner, Kanadier für eine Woche, für zwei Wochen.
Wobei im ATV noch keine Astronauten mitfliegen.
Nein, aber die Astronauten sind natürlich mit der, also müssen Tätigkeiten da durchführen.
Die müssen das empfangen und damit arbeiten vor Ort.
Ganz genau. Und vor allem das Andox-Verfahren müssen sie überwachen. Und das ist vielleicht das wichtigste Teil der Ausbildung. Ja, und dann kamen wir. Und dann wurde es natürlich hier ein bisschen stressiger für die Trainings-Community, weil sie eben diese Grundausbildung anbieten mussten. Es ist losgegangen für die ersten Monate mit Theorie hauptsächlich. Also wir sind wirklich so ein bisschen wie in die Schule zurückgegangen, im Klassenzimmer gesessen und wir haben zugehört, wie Wissenschaftler, Experten, Techniker aus ganz Europa, aus der Uni oder aus der Industrie oder aus Forschungseinrichtungen von verschiedenen Gebieten erzählt haben. Also das ging von Biologie bis Computernetzwerke, Raumfahrtmechanik, Fluidmechanik, also wirklich alles Mögliche, so kleine Blöcke, weil es wichtig ist, dass die Astronauten auch ein Grundwissen haben in diesen Bereichen. Und Astronauten kommen aus verschiedenen Berufen. Also natürlich könnte theoretisch, also das ist bei uns nicht der Fall, aber ein Arenahrtster sein und ein Biologe, da kennt sich natürlich aus in Biologie, da weiß aber wahrscheinlich ein bisschen wenig von Raumfahrtmechanik. Und umgekehrt, es können Raumfahrtingenieure dabei sein, die wahrscheinlich von Biologie nichts können. Und alle müssen einen gemeinsamen Grundwissen haben.
Du hast ja Maschinenbau gemacht, schon mit Schwerpunkt Luft-
und Raumfahrttechnik.
Das war ja sicherlich dann schon sehr hilfreich bei dieser Ausbildung, oder?
Doch, also ein bisschen Grundwissen schon zu haben, das ist natürlich wichtig. Aber wie gesagt, von Biologie habe ich nichts gewusst.
Was mich noch Frage ist, was ist denn bei der Maschinenbau, ist ja nun wirklich auch ein sehr weites Feld. Was ist denn dann die Spezialisierung auf Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik? Was macht das konkret aus?
Also man vertieft die Bereiche, die dann relevant sind. Das geht eben von Luftfahrt- und Raumfahrtmechanik bis auf wirklich Flugzeugkonstruktion oder Raumfahrtkonstruktion. Aber auch etwas allgemeiner Fächer wie Flutmechanik, Turbinen, solche Sachen, die dann natürlich nicht nur in der Raumfahrt angewendet werden, aber für Luft- und Raumfahrtingenieure natürlich eine Pflicht sind.
Und jetzt hier hast du dann quasi auch die anderen Disziplinen dann teilweise das erste Mal vielleicht überhaupt erst entgegen genommen. Das ist dann auch nicht gerade wenig, oder? Da muss man wirklich eine Menge poken.
Ja, man muss auch sagen, man verleint jetzt nicht von den Astronauten, dass sie jetzt plötzlich Experten sind in allen Feldern. Es geht ja wirklich nur darum, dass sie ein Grundwissen haben, auch eine gemeinsame Sprache entwickeln mit den Wissenschaftlern. Wenn man dann in der Zukunft auf einem Biologie-Experiment ausgebildet wird, wo man mit dem Wissenschaftler redet oder mit den Ausbildern redet, ist es einfach wichtig, die große Zusammenhänge mal gehört zu haben, eine gemeinsame Sprache zu haben, damit man sich da verständigt und was davon versteht. Also klar, niemand erwartet von uns, dass wir jetzt plötzlich Experten sind in allen Feldern. Das ist klar. Parallel dazu ging die Ausbildung in der russischen Sprache. Das ist ganz wichtig, weil Russisch die zweite offizielle Sprache auf der Raumstation ist, zusammen mit dem Englischen. Die Russen haben fast die Hälfte der Raumstation beigetragen. Und die Russen sind auch diejenigen, die in den letzten Jahren als Einzige die Möglichkeit geben, Crews, also Menschen auf die Raumstation zu bringen, mit der Rakete, das Soyuz-Rakete und das Soyuz-Kapsel. Das heißt, es ist ganz wichtig, sich Russischkenntnisse anzuweigen. Und da hat ESA wirklich eine gezielte Wahl getroffen, das von vornherein und gleich als einen Schwerpunkt zu setzen. Das heißt, es gab dann gleich am Anfang, in den ersten Monaten, drei Monate Intensivkurs, also zuerst hier in Deutschland, und dann die Kollegen gingen noch für einen ganzen Monat in St. Petersburg. Die haben wirklich bei Familien gewohnt und jeden Tag, dann praktisch den ganzen Arbeitstag, Russischunterricht gehabt. Und deswegen haben sie auch sehr schnell Russisch gelernt. Ja, ich konnte das schon. Das heißt, ich habe nur am Anfang, im ersten Monat, da mitgemacht, um das ein bisschen aufzufrischen und mich auf die Prüfung vorzubereiten und habe dann gleich auch die Prüfung gemacht.
Also es geht wirklich um das, wie soll ich sagen, das normale Russisch. Es geht gar nicht so sehr um ein wissenschaftliches Russisch.
Es geht am Anfang wirklich um das normale Russische.
Also wichtig ist sozusagen, dass man einfach mit den anderen kommunizieren kann, dass man Kontakt mit der Bodenstation etc. alles locker durchführen kann. Das ist sozusagen das Ziel an der Stelle.
Aber auch, dass man mit der Ausbildung im Stellenstädtchen zurechtkommt. Also okay, im Prinzip könnte man auch Übersetzer benutzen, aber es ist natürlich viel einfacher, wenn man direkt mit den Leuten sprechen kann. Auch das Leben, die Umstände, das Ganze wird viel einfacher, wenn man komfortabel ist mit der Sprache und man versteht, was da los ist. Deswegen ist es schon ganz wichtig und es macht einen riesen Unterschied. Genau, und dann ging es weiter mit der Ausbildung auf den europäischen Teilen der Raumstation. Also wir haben das ein bisschen gemacht, was wie gesagt alle Crews hier machen. Also Ausbildung auf dem Columbus und auf dem ATV und auf die Payloads. Das heißt die Ausrüstung, die im Columbus ist, um die Experimente zu unterstützen. Also wir haben jetzt keine Ausbildung bekommen in speziellen Experimenten, das wäre ja sinnlos, weil da muss man wirklich wissen, was in dem Moment gemacht wird, wann man eigentlich fliegt. Aber die festen Einrichtungen, die da sind, bleiben natürlich und da sind wir auch ausgebildet geworden. Und parallel dazu haben wir mit dem, was man GRT, also Generic Robotics Training nennt. Und das ist eine ganz spezielle Tätigkeit der Astronauten an Bord, zusammen mit den EVA, die Extra Vehicular Activities. Also das sind ein bisschen die zwei Tätigkeiten, die wirklich sehr speziell im Astronautenleben vorkommen.
Also Extra Vehicular Activity heißt Raumspaziergang.
Ja, Raumspaziergang, das nennt man in Italienisch schon auch so. Spaziergang, ich weiß nicht, wer dazugekommen ist auf diese Definition.
So ein schönes Bild.
Ja, aber ein Spaziergang ist das wirklich nicht.
Man stellt sich das ja so vor, man wacht morgens auf und nach dem Frühstück, ach, ich mach jetzt mal einen kleinen Spaziergang.
Genau, das ist eigentlich überhaupt die aufwendigste Tätigkeit auf der Raumstation und auch im Training wirklich das vielleicht das schwierigste und das anstrengendste. Deswegen ein Spaziergang, das hilft so bestimmt nicht zu. Aber was man hier in der Grundausbildung gemacht hat, ist eine Einführung in diese Weltraumspaziergänge. Die eigentliche Ausbildung wird dann bei der NASA in Houston gemacht mit den eigentlichen Anzügen, mit den echten Anzügen, die man da an hat. Aber was man sich hier überlegt hat, ist, wie kann man mit einfachen Mitteln, weil wir die Anzüge hier ja nicht haben, unseren Astronauten einen Vorteil geben bei dieser Ausbildung, also dass sie schon was können und was wissen, wenn sie da hinkommen. Und die Leute hier haben sich diesen Einführungskurs überlegt, indem wir in dem Schwimmbecken, der ist jetzt 10 Meter tiefer, Szenarien üben und einige der Schwierigkeiten simulieren, die mit dem Anzug verbunden sind, zum Beispiel die Handschuhe. Also eine der Schwierigkeiten ist, dass man diese ganz große und unbequemen Handschuhe hat, weil der Anzug ist ja pressurisiert, da ist ja Druck drin. Das heißt, Hände zu machen, zum Beispiel Haken auf und zu machen, das muss man immer wieder machen in diesen Wettkampfspaziergängen. Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr schwierig und sehr, sehr anstrengend für die Hände. Das simulieren wir hier, indem wir eben sehr steife und große Handschuhe tragen. Also das ist natürlich nicht mit Druck drin, aber diese Schwierigkeit wird simuliert. Wir haben dann zum Beispiel Stiefel, mit denen man sich in diese PFR, das sind Befestigungseinrichtungen für die Füße, einhaken kann. Das heißt, wir können auch üben, wie man da rein und rauskommt.
Was heißt das?
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo das akronymisch ist. Aber das sind so Befestigungseinrichtungen, da kann man sich mit diesen Stiefeln reinhaken. Dann ist man da fest eingehakt und das bringt dazu, dass man mit den Händen frei arbeiten kann. Man muss sich denken, in einem Weltraumspaziergang muss man immer befestigt sein, sonst fliegt man irgendwo rum. Und nicht nur das, sondern man muss immer an die Gegenkräfte und Gegenmomente denken, wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Schraubenzieher drehen möchte. Wenn ich anfange zu drehen, was im Weltraum passiert, wenn ich nicht befestigt bin, ist einfach, dass mein Körper dann anfängt, in die andere Richtung zu drehen. Das heißt, man muss immer irgendwie steif befestigt. Und diese PFRs ermöglichen das. Und das ist so ein bisschen ein Skill.
Das heißt, da wird der Fuß so richtig eingeklingt, richtig fest reingeparkt.
Richtig fest und so eine steife Verbindung, ja. Weil das macht man, wenn man zum Arbeitsplatz kommt und man arbeitet. Wenn man aber zum Beispiel sich bewegt, der Raum steht dann entlang, weil man zum Arbeitsplatz ja kommen muss, dann muss man sich entweder mit einer Hand immer festhalten oder man muss immer so hacken, ein und ein hacken in diesen Rails, damit man immer eine Verbindung hat. Es ist ein bisschen wie Bergsteigen, ja. Und dazu hat man natürlich noch ein Sicherheitsdraht, der irgendwie dann immer mitläuft, sagen wir mal. Das ist so eine zweite Sicherheit. Und man muss alle Instrumente, alle Tools, die man mitnimmt, müssen auch immer befestigt sein, entweder an sich oder auf der Station. Deswegen habe ich gesagt, man muss immer wieder ständig hacken, auf- und zumachen, vier, sechs, sieben Stunden mit diesen ganz steifen Handschuhen. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz so ein Spaziergang.
Ist das im Wesentlichen Krafttraining, oder geht es darum, dass man so den Prozess einfach so verinnerlicht, dass man den nicht falsch machen kann?
Beides. Also, okay, Krafttraining, aber das muss man auch nebenbei machen, das muss man auch ein bisschen außerhalb vom Schwimmbad machen. Aber es geht wirklich darum, dieses Protokoll, dieses Safety-Protokoll nennt man das, sich fast unbewusst anzu-eigenen, dass man fast nicht mehr daran denken muss und spontan immer fast unbewusst.
Macht man das dann zu Hause dann auch irgendwann so?
Also wir versuchen zu Hause nicht mit Haken umzulaufen, sonst wär's natürlich gefährlich.
Ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Das ERC, wo wir uns jetzt hier befinden, das ist so, muss man sich vorstellen, das ist im Wesentlichen so eine große Halle, das hat so zwei große Hallen, das hat natürlich auch ein Büro-Trakt, aber der eigentliche Ausbildungsbereich besteht einerseits aus dem Bereich, wo die ganzen Module von den Raumstationen, alles, wo man so hin will, also auch die Sojus-Kapsel, das ist mehr oder weniger hier alles eins zu eins, liegt das hier rum und kann so ausprobiert werden. Und der zweite große Teil ist dieses Schwimmbäcken. Und dieses Becken ist im Wesentlichen für das Erlernen der Schwerelosigkeit gedacht. Kann man das so sagen? Wie groß ist dieses Schwimmbäcken?
Also, Durchmesser weiß ich eigentlich nicht, aber das Wichtigste ist, es ist 10 Meter tief. Das heißt, man kann eine Replika vom Columbus-Labor da wirklich eintauchen. Und es geht darum, zu lernen, wie man in der Schwerelosigkeit arbeitet. Weil wir können auf der Erde die Schwerelosigkeit an sich nicht reproduzieren. Also der einzige Weg, aber für ganz kurze Zeiten, sind die Parabellflüge. Das war auch Teil unserer Ausbildung. Aber wenn man jetzt Vorgänge üben muss, die über viele Stunden gehen, das kann man natürlich im Parabellflug nicht machen. Und der Einzelweg ist, das unter Wasser zu machen. Da ist die Schwerelosigkeit natürlich nicht weg. Aber man schwebt, sagen wir mal, im Wasser. Genau, wie vom Tauchen. Die Astronauten, die das auch wirklich im Weltraum gemacht haben, sagen auch, dass es einfacher ist im Weltraum. Weil da ist man auch wirklich schwerelos.
Da ist der Widerstand nicht so groß.
Da ist der Widerstand nicht so groß. Da wiegt der Körper auch nichts. Ich find's eigentlich sehr gut. Von der Luftwaffen-Ausbildung kenn ich das. Man hat immer bei uns gesagt, train hard, fight easy. Also immer das Härter haben in der Ausbildung, damit es dann im echten Einsatz einfacher wird. Das scheint bei diesen Schwimmböcken-Ausbildenden der Fall zu sein durchaus. Wenn man das dann wirklich macht im Weltraumkommen, noch andere Faktoren dazu. Die Erwartungen, der Stress. Man kann wirklich keine Fehler machen. Dann ist es ganz gut, wenn einige andere Sachen einfacher sind. Einfach Körper bewegen, also Rotationen, Torsionen. Hier muss man wirklich Kraft ausüben, weil Wasserwiderstand, wie gesagt, und der Körper wiegt ja eigentlich.
Das heißt, wenn man das jetzt hier trainiert, es gibt hier diese Replika von einem Columbus-Modul, also dem Teil, wo im Wesentlichen die europäischen Experimente drin durchgeführt werden. Das sieht genauso aus, also da ist jetzt keine Technik drin. Es geht nur darum, dass man dieselbe Größe hat und vor allem, dass man die ganzen Außenhaken etc. wahrscheinlich alles hat. Und da gibt es so einen riesigen Kran, der fährt das dann über dieses Becken und taucht das komplett ein. Und dann geht man mit der kompletten Montur unter Wasser. Aber es ist jetzt nicht diese selbe Ausrüstung, es ist nicht derselbe Anzug, hast du gesagt.
Genau. Wir haben in Europa diesen Anzug nicht. Es würde sich wahrscheinlich jetzt finanziell nicht lohnen, in Europa so einen Anzug selbst zu entwickeln oder die ganze Ausbildung mit dem Anzug auch hier zu machen, weil wir jetzt nicht so viele sind. Das wäre wahrscheinlich...
Das Prinzip, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist, es gibt ja verschiedene Ausbildungsstandorte. Hier ist einer, Sternstädtchen, das Bekannte in Russland, dann in den USA, in Houston. Gibt es noch andere?
Ja, und zwar die Kanadier machen ein paar Wochen Ausbildung auf dem Canadarm, also diese robotische Arm außerhalb der Raumstation. Und die Japaner bilden natürlich auf die japanischen Beiträge zur Raumstation, also das japanische Laboa und das japanische Cargo-Shift, das HTV.
Das heißt, jeder bildet sozusagen nur genau für die Technik aus, die er auch beiträgt dem gesamten Projekt.
Genau, das ist genau der Prinzip.
Und da halt der Raumfahrtanzug von den Amerikanern kommt, macht man das auch dort, weil er hat nicht nur den Anzug, sondern auch die Experten das Wissen, etc.
Ja, genau.
Aber trotzdem ist das hier ein Teil der Ausbildung.
Genau, das ist ein Teil unserer Grundausbildung gewesen und das ist eigentlich so nützlich, weil wenn man dann nicht hinkommt zur Nase und zum ersten Mal dann in den großen Anzug ins Becken eingetaucht wird und alles natürlich schwieriger wird dadurch, hat man aber schon irgendwelche Kenntnisse und Skills, gerade wie wir gesagt haben. Einige Sachen sind schon automatisch geworden und das macht es natürlich einfacher.
Und wie ist das so unter Wasser dann? Ist das irgendwie schwierig, komisch?
Man muss sich natürlich an die Umgebung gewöhnen. Das ist eine total unterschiedliche Umgebung zu dem, was man gewöhnt ist. Es ist auch nicht unbedingt so viel mit Tauchen verbunden. Weil viele Sachen, worum man sich kümmern müsste im Tauchen, also Navigieren, Luft und solche Sachen, darum kümmern sich die Astronauten nicht. Da gibt es Taucher, darum kümmern sie sich. Der Astronaut muss wirklich irgendwie in die Vorstellung kommen, dass er ein Weltraum ist.
Also man ist auch nicht alleine da unten, sondern man ist da mit mir.
Es gibt verschiedene Sicherheitstaucher drumrum. Sie kümmern sich, dass zum Beispiel die beuern sie. Weiß ich gar nicht auf Deutsch jetzt. Aufgetrieben ist auch immer so geregelt, dass der Astronaut nicht irgendwie nach oben steigt oder nach unten. Da würde ein Taucher das selbe machen müssen. Da kümmert sich der Astronaut nicht. Luft wird eigentlich von oben durch Schläuche gegeben. Das heißt, man muss jetzt nicht darum kümmern, dass man jetzt keine Luft hat plötzlich. Falls irgendwas passiert, haben die Sicherheits-Taucher Prozeduren, um da einzugreifen. Also das alles, das Unterwasser sein, das sollte dem Astronauten keine Sorgen vorbereiten, weil dafür wird er nicht ausgebildet. Er wird dazu ausgebildet, im Weltraum zu sein. Und alles, was damit verbunden ist, unter Wasser zu sein, darum kümmern sich andere.
Also ich bin kein guter Schwimmer und auch kein guter Taucher, aber als ich mal so einen Tauchlehrgang gemacht habe, war das für mich vor allem so das Gefühl, ich bin eigentlich an einem Ort, wo ein Mensch nicht hingehört. Das ist ja nun eigentlich in der Raumstation genauso. Ist das sozusagen auch so ein Gefühl, was man dann mitbekommt bei solchen Tests, dass man eigentlich überhaupt erst mal lernt, sich daran zu gewöhnen, dass man in einer lebensfeindlichen Umgebung ist?
Also ich hab das jetzt so eigentlich persönlich nicht erlebt. Wir waren ja auch alle Taucher, als wir da gekommen sind. Das heißt vielleicht mit der Tatsache, dass man unter Wasser auch leben kann, waren wir alle vertraut. Also ich hab das jetzt so nicht erlebt.
Das war sozusagen schon Teil deiner vorherigen Ausbildung? Gut, da warst du wahrscheinlich schon so sehr dran gewöhnt, dass es schon keine Besonderheit mehr dargestellt hat.
Bei den anderen genauso, glaub ich. Wir waren alle Taucher.
Und der zweite Teil, den du von erwähnt hast, dieses Generic-Robotic-Training, was empfasst das?
Also das Ziel ist, dass man dann auf der Raumstation dieses Kanada, dieses robotische Manipulator, das außerhalb der Station ist, manipulieren oder betätigen kann. Damit ist praktisch die Station zusammengebaut worden. Das heißt jedes Mal, dass ein Modul hochgeschossen worden ist, zum Beispiel mit dem Space Shuttle, da muss man dieses Modul aus dem Space Shuttle raus mit diesem Kanada rausnehmen, zum Andockpunkt bringen, damit es dann wirklich angedockt werden konnte. Was man auch damit macht, ist das sogenannte Birthing. Das heißt, zum Beispiel das ATV, das japanische Cargo-Schiff, im Unterschied zum ATV, das europäische Cargo-Schiff, kann nicht automatisch docken. Das heißt, er kommt, er nähert sich der Raumstation und fliegt da mit der Raumstation sozusagen in Formationsflug. Da bleibt, sagen wir, stehen, relativ zur Raumstation. Und dann die Astronauten fangen das ein mit dem Kanada und machen das Birthing, das heißt das Docken, sagen wir, an die Raumstation. Um das machen zu können, muss man dann Schritt für Schritt so die Skills einigen oder Fähigkeiten einigen. Und das GRT, Generic Robotics Training, ist wirklich so ein Skills-Based Training. Das heißt, man hat noch nicht mit allen Fähigkeiten von dem Kanada zu tun und mit der Umgebung der Raumstation. Das kommt später. Also man hat mit einem etwas einfacheren Arm zu tun, in einem Simulator, das ist wie ein bisschen ein Computerspiel, sagen wir mal, und eine einfache Umgebung. Das ist einfach so ein Raum. Und man lernt, Sachen zu machen wie zum Beispiel Grappling, also Module zu fangen, sich zu bestimmten Punkten bewegen und wie gesagt wieder diese Safety-Protokolls, also diese Sicherheitsprotokolle zu beachten, also immer einen gewissen Abstand zu halten. Die Geschwindigkeiten, mit denen man den Roboten, den Kanada bewegen kann, hängen davon ab, wie weit man von der Wand ist oder von irgendwelchen Objekten ist. Solche Sachen lernt man einfach mit diesem Kurs. Und dann, wenn man das gemacht hat, das haben wir alle gemacht, ist der nächste Schritt eben die Ausbildung richtig auf dem Kanada. Das heißt, es kommt dann ein Arm dazu, der etwas mehr Fähigkeiten hat, also Freiheitsgrade sagen wir mal, und die Umgebung kommt dazu. Also man bewegt sich dann nicht in einem einfachen Raum, sondern wirklich im Außenbereich der Raumstation.
Wie gesagt, Kanadarm, also es ist sozusagen Kanada, der Arm von Kanada, der an der ISS dranhängt. Was macht man denn damit sonst noch? Außer, dass man jetzt das HTV einfängt?
Ja, also wie gesagt, wenn ein neuer Modul jetzt, wird in der Zukunft natürlich selten vorkommen, dass ein neuer Modul kommt, aber einfach das zusammenbauen, ist dann mehr oder weniger zu komplett. Wenn zum Beispiel Wartungsarbeiten von Astronauten außerhalb der Raumstation gemacht werden und ein Astronaut wirklich von einem Teil der Raumstation bis zum anderen Teil der Raumstation sich bewegen muss. Die Raumstation ist inzwischen sehr groß, das ist 100 Meter mal 73 ungefähr. Da würde der Astronaut so lange unterwegs sein, das geht ja alles wirklich sehr langsam. Also es könnte sein, dass der Astronaut sich in so einem PFR mit den Füßen einhäckt, am Ende von dem Canadarm und dann von dem Canadarm relativ schnell dann von einer Seite der Station zum anderen Seite bewegt wird. Das kommt auch vor.
Das heißt, man kann auch mal so Astronauten verpflanzen.
Zum Beispiel.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht typischerweise der Fall, aber das könnte sein?
Nein, das ist schon regelmäßig vorgekommen. Oder ganz schwere Teile, die ausgetauscht werden müssen, also wenn sie so wirklich groß und schwer sind, könnte es sein, dass sie dann mit dem Canadarm bewegt werden. Oder dass sie eigentlich von den Astronauten in die Hände genommen werden, aber dann doch mit dem Astronauten zusammen mit dem Canadarm bewegt werden. Weil ein Astronaut könnte sich dann sehr schwer mit einem sehr großen und schweren Teil sehr lange der Raumschätze entlang bewegen.
Ist eigentlich jeder Teil der Besatzung auf der ISS auch mal außerhalb tätig sein?
Leider nicht.
Wir würden das alle gerne machen. Wir werden alle dazu ausgebildet, weil es könnte jederzeit passieren, dass ein Notfall vorkommt und man muss raus. Deswegen muss jeder dazu ausgebildet sein. Aber für so geplante Tätigkeiten aus der Raumstation werden von vornherein zwei Crewmembers, zwei Mitglieder zugeteilt und die anderen nicht.
Also ist es mal wieder Glück. Dann muss man von den sechs nochmal auf zwei runter. Wie lange wird denn die ganze Ausbildung insgesamt gedauert haben? Wann ist man denn fertig? Jetzt haben wir eineinhalb Jahre, glaube ich, durch.
Ja, also sagen wir so, wenn man dann zu einer Besatzung zugeteilt wird und wenn man jetzt annimmt, dass man dazwischen nichts gemacht hat, also außer der Grundausbildung, dann würde man ungefähr über zweieinhalb Jahre zu tun haben, um das alles absolviert zu haben. Das ist dann wirklich ohne Pausen durchgehend. Was dann normalerweise vorgab, ist zum Beispiel mein Kollege Luca Parmitano, ist zugeteilt worden zu einem Flug in 2013. Das heißt, das ist bei ihm dann der Fall gewesen. Er hat gleich angefangen und zwei, anderthalb Jahre Ausbildung und dann gleich Start. Was bei uns anderen der Fall sein wird, ist, dass wir ein bisschen mehr Zeit haben und wir werden Teile dieser Ausbildung machen und dann immer zwischendurch Pausen und dann wieder nochmal ein bisschen Ausbildung, Pausen. Weil es gibt Sachen, die gemacht werden müssen. Zum Beispiel das Training im Schwimmbäcken bei der NASA oder dieses Canadarm-Training. Die müssen wir alle machen. Und es gibt dann Teile vom Training, die dann mehr flugbezogen sind. Wenn man dann zugeteilt wird zur Besatzung, dann fängt man damit an. Es wird aber bei uns nicht zweieinhalb Jahre dauern, sondern vielleicht ein bisschen weniger, weil wir dazwischen noch was dazugelernt haben werden.
Aber die eigentliche Grundausbildung ist jetzt auch noch nicht ganz vorbei. Es gibt jetzt immer noch Dinge, die...
Doch, die Grundausbildung ist vorbei. Wir sind im November letztes Jahr fertig geworden. Also die offizielle Grundausbildung ist dann vorbei gewesen zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Haben wir denn dann jetzt schon alles abgedeckt, was zu dieser Grundausbildung dazugehört? Also wir hatten erstmal die grundlegende wissenschaftliche Basisausbildung. Man muss alles mal kennenlernen. Man muss auch die Bereiche, wo man selbst kein Spezialist ist, soweit rein vertieft werden, dass man zumindest in einer Lage ist, jederzeit so ein Briefing über konkrete Experimente zu verstehen. So habe ich das verstanden. Dann muss man lernen, mit der Raumstation als solcher umzugehen. Also man muss drumherum fliegen können. Dafür gibt es das Schwimmbecken. Aber man muss sich ja auch mit der Raumstation als solcher überhaupt erstmal vertraut machen. Wir hatten jetzt über den einen Teil hier im ERC ja schon gesprochen, über das große Schwimmbecken mit dem großen Arm und diesem Columbus-Modul Mock-Up. Auf der anderen Seite der Halle gibt es dann wiederum andere Komponenten. Also da ist auch noch mal ein Columbus-Modul, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Aber auch diese Soyuz-Kapsel, mit der man dann ja hochfliegen wird. Was macht man da?
Also die Soyuz-Simulator, den wir hier hatten, ist wirklich nur ein bisschen, um sich damit vertraut zu machen. Vor allem mit den dynamischen Teilen und so weiter. Aber die eigentliche Soyuz-Ausbildung wird in Sternenstädtchen gemacht. Also was wir gemacht haben, als Teil unserer Grundausbildung, ist Einführung in die Soyuz-Theorie, das wurde schon hier mehr erzählt gemacht. Und dann im Sternenstädtchen einige Simulationen haben wir gemacht für die dynamischen Teilen des Fluges, also Start und dann Andocken und dann wieder Eintritt in die Atmosphäre. Das war wirklich so eine Einführung, damit wir ein bisschen verstehen, was da los ist. Aber die eigentliche Ausbildung, um ein Besatzungsmitglied eines Soyuz zu sein, das dauert mehrere Monate und das ist auch sehr intensiv. Und wie gesagt, das kommt, wenn man zu einer Besatzung zugeteilt wäre. Das ist nicht Teil der Grundausbildung und das wird im Sternenstädtchen gemacht. Was wir hier gemacht haben, ist die Ausbildung auf dem ATV. Das ist ja eben ein europäischer Beitrag. Was muss man da machen? Das ATV ist ein Schiff, aber wenn es oben ist, da kann bis sechs Monate angedeckt bleiben auf der Raumstation, da wird wirklich ein zusätzliches Modul der Raumstation sein. Das ist zum Beispiel im Moment der Fall. Wir haben ja vor einem Monat ungefähr Johannes Keppel, das ATV R2 in den Weltraum geschickt von Kuro. Er ist jetzt auf der Raumstation als zusätzlicher Modul. Das heißt, man muss auf dem Modul ausgebildet werden. Aber was ganz wichtig ist, ist die Beobachtung und Überwachung des Undocks-Verfahrens. Weil ATV ist ganz speziell, da kann man wirklich automatisch undocken an die Raumstation mit einer Genauigkeit von zwei Zentimeter. Das ist wirklich unerhört. Also es ist eine sehr hohe Genauigkeit. Und es ist auch eine europäische Entwicklung, worüber wir stolz sind.
Hat auch wieder problemlos funktioniert. Ich hatte nach der Aufnahme des letzten Podcasts dann noch die Gelegenheit, das dann noch live zu verfolgen im Kolumbus-Kontrollzentrum. Und ein erstaunlicher Prozess. Das nähert sich ja erstmal, bleibt eine Weile stehen, nähert sich noch ein bisschen, bleibt eine Weile stehen. Und wenn man sich dann irgendwie sicher ist, kacchan. Aber trotzdem, es gab dann immer so wechselnde, wechselnde Kameraperspektiven. Also man merkte richtig, dass die Astronauten an Bord aktiv dieses Geschehen begleitet haben, die Kamera neu ausgerichtet haben und das beobachtet werden. Das heißt, man wird für den Fall ausgebildet, dass es eben mal mit der Automatik vielleicht doch nicht so gut funktioniert.
Genau, weil wenn alles automatisch läuft, dann müssen Astronauten eigentlich wirklich nur beobachten. Aber in den Simulationen geht natürlich immer alles schief, in allen möglichen Art und Weisen. Und da muss man eben zeigen können, dass man die richtige Reaktion hat im richtigen Moment, das Richtige tut in einer kurzen Zeit.
Das heißt aber auch, dass nicht nur die europäischen Astronauten für ATV ausgebildet werden, sondern auch Astronauten, die jetzt aus Russland oder Amerika kommen. Das heißt, die kommen dann auch hierher und bekommen ihre ATV-Ausbildung.
Ja, also wenn sie zu dieser Aufgabe zugeteilt werden, also ATV-Überwachung, dann ja, also nicht unbedingt alle fix. Also wenn wir einen europäischen Besatzungsmitglied an Bord haben, wie jetzt der Fall ist mit Paul von Espirit, dann ist natürlich er oder sie derjenige oder diejenige, die Operator One, sagen wir, also der Hauptverantwortliche ist. Das wird immer zu zweit gemacht. Also es gibt auch so einen zweiten Besatzungsmitglieder, der dazu hilft. In den meisten Fällen ein Russe, weil da ATV ein bisschen mit den Russen entwickelt wurde und teilweise auch russische Technik.
Docking ist ja auch eine russische, wird ja auch immer nur durchgeführt, wenn man sich über russischem Gebiet befindet. Deswegen gibt es diese klaren Zeitfenster. Das ist also sozusagen eine russische Hoheitsaufgabe an der Stelle.
Weil wir das russische Docking-System benutzt haben für das ATV. Genau. Deswegen sagen wir mal, normalerweise werden die Kosmonauten zum ATV ausgebildet, zusammen mit den europäischen Kosmonauten. Aber das erste ATV, Jules Verne, wurde von Peggy Whitson überwacht. Unter anderem. Und die ist natürlich eine Amerikanerin. Also es kann ein bisschen unterschiedlich vorkommen.
Die Kooperation ist ja da sehr ausgeprägt.
Genau.
Aber trotzdem ist es schon mal hilfreich, sich hier mit einer Soyuz-Kapsel auch vertraut zu machen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und zu wissen, wie eng das wird. Und was macht man dann so mit den... Also was gibt es hier sonst noch, außer dem, was Sie erwähnt haben?
Also jetzt als Sachen, die wirklich da sind, glaube ich, haben wir das mehr oder weniger erschöpft. Was jetzt Trainingsangst geht, also es gibt natürlich auch Konsolen, wo zum Beispiel die Eurocoms mit dem Columbus oder mit Astronauten im Columbus-Labor sprechen. Also diese Eurocoms sind nicht unbedingt immer im Columbus-Kontrollzentrum, im Oberpfaffenhofen, weil das sind dann Kollegen von uns, vom ERC.
Also Eurocoms sind die Leute, die den Kontakt halten mit den Astronauten im Columbus-Modul.
Genau. Wir haben in Oberpfaffenhofen, also in der Nähe von München, das Columbus-Kontrollzentrum. Da sitzen natürlich viele Leute, die die verschiedenen Systeme von Columbus überwachen. Aber wie es so ist in allen Kontrollzentren, es gibt immer nur ein Mensch, der mit den Astronauten an Bord redet. Und der heißt zum Beispiel der NASA Capcom. Und bei uns in Europa heißt dieser Mensch Eurocom.
Warum ist es nur einer?
Weil das wäre sehr verwirrend für die Astronauten, wenn plötzlich alle möglichen Leute in die Frequenz da reinspringen und was sagen, erstens mal. Und zweitens, die Kommunikation wäre sehr unordentlich. Man würde nicht wissen, wer jetzt gerade auf Frequenz ist und spricht.
Aber auch so über den Tag hinweg ist das wirklich nur eine Person?
Also das Eurocom. Das Eurocom kann im Laufe der Tage natürlich wechseln.
Aber es ist sozusagen zu jedem Zeitpunkt, gibt es immer nur eine Person, mit der man redet.
Genau, oder eine Figur, sagen wir, das Eurocom. Und die Eurocoms sind Kollegen von uns. Unter anderem auch wir Astronauten werden zu Eurocoms ausgebildet. Also zwei meiner Kollegen haben damit schon angefangen. Oder Trainers, also auf jeden Fall Leute vom ERC. Teilweise reisen sie zum Kolumbus-Kontrollzentrum im Oberpfaffenhofen. Und teilweise machen sie das von hier. Deswegen haben wir auch hier Eurocom-Konsolen. Wir haben Konsolen von den Biomedical Engineers. Das sind Leute hier vom ERC, also von unserer medizinischen Abteilung, die dafür verantwortlich sind, die Lebensqualität an Bord zu überwachen, dass es den Astronauten gut geht. Es ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich vom Arzt. Die Ärzte an Konsolen beschäftigen sich wirklich mit der Gesundheit von Astronauten. Also wir unsere Ärzte auf dem Boden. Aber die Biomedical Engineers, die müssen sich wirklich auch mit den Lebensumständen beschäftigen, dass es den Astronauten gut geht, also wirklich auch, was die Umgebung angeht.
Oder was ist das Aufgabengebiet in dem Fall genau?
Also sie können sich zum Beispiel mit Sachen beschäftigen, wie die CO2 auf der Raumstation ist zu hoch. Und ein Astronaut könnte da zum Beispiel damit Probleme haben. Die Astronauten können das mit den Biomedical Engineers dann besprechen. Und die Biomedical Engineers sind dann diejenigen, die das dann als Problem hervorrufen oder besprechen dann in den internationalen Control-Centers.
Das heißt, an der Stelle braucht man dann auch wieder die notwendige Grundausbildung selbst, um solche Sachen auch überhaupt entsprechend ansprechen zu können?
Also unsere Grundausbildung hat nicht nur hier stattgefunden, sondern einige Teile der Grundausbildung haben woanders stattgefunden. Also zum Beispiel, ich habe schon erwähnt, dass wir die Möglichkeit gehabt haben, an einem Parabelflug teilzunehmen. Das macht man im Bordeaux. Es gibt eine Firma, die heißt Novespass, und die bietet diese Möglichkeit, diese Parabelflüge zu machen. ESA hat jedes Jahr mehrere Parabelflug-Kampagnen, wo normalerweise Experimente geflogen werden, also von Wissenschaftlern, die eben diese 22 Sekunden Schwerelosigkeitsbedingungen bei jeder Parabel ausnutzen wollen für ihre Experimente. Aber eben bei diesen Flugern haben wir da die Möglichkeit genutzt, die Schwerelosigkeit zum ersten Mal zu erleben. Also zuerst war es ein Riesenspaß, muss ich zugeben. Wir haben das auch wirklich als spielerisch ein bisschen genossen. Aber es ging auch darum, wirklich Übungen zu machen, speziell was diese Einsätze außerhalb der Raumstation, diese Weltraumspaziergänge angeht. Also wir hatten damals schon ein bisschen Ausbildung in dem Becken gemacht und es ging darum zu sehen, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Schwerelosigkeit, Simulation sagen wir im Schwimmböcken und echte Schwerelosigkeit im Parabelflug. Also wie bewegt sich der Körper? Wie hart muss ich meine Muskeln anspannen im Vergleich zur Unterwassertätigkeit, wenn ich da wirklich schwerelos bin? Wie reagiert mein Körper? Wie reagieren Objekte? Was passiert, wenn ich etwas werfe, wenn ich versuche, etwas zu drehen? Da gab es bei uns wirklich ein Aha-Effekt. Das haben wir alles vorher sehen können. Aber das ist völlig was anderes, wenn man das im eigenen Körper erlebt.
Vielleicht sagen wir noch mal kurz diese Situation im Parabelflug. Wir reden über ein Flugzeug. Was ist das?
Das ist ein A300 von einem Airbus. Das ist praktisch drin leer gemacht worden. Die Wände sind so ein bisschen gepolstert, dass man sich nicht zu wehtut, wenn man fällt. Nach 22 Sekunden ist die Schwerelosigkeit weg. Wenn man zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht zum Boden gekommen ist, dann fällt man richtig auf den Boden.
Das heißt, es ist rundherum gepolstert?
Rundherum gepolstert, ja. Wie gesagt, für unseren Flug wurde es speziell relativ leer. Normalerweise ist es ein bisschen mehr eingeteilt für die verschiedenen Experimente. Wir hatten da verschiedene Stationen mit verschiedenen Übungen. Wir sind an der Reihe nach durch diese Stationen gegangen und dann verschiedene Sachen ausprobiert. Also z.B. unser Körper um 90° oder 180° zu drehen.
Um kurz zu verstehen, was passiert. Das Flugzeug startet, fliegt hoch und dann fliegt es quasi so ein Bogen, eben diese Parabel. Und ich weiß nicht genau, wann setzt dann die Schwerelosigkeit das erste Mal ein?
Wann das Flugzeug in diese Parabel reinkommt. Also es ist ein bisschen so, man lernt das immer in der Schule. Wenn man z.B. einen Stein wirft, der bildet in der Luft eine Parabel und irgendwann fällt das runter. Also was man da tut, ist, dass man, man kann sich vorstellen, ich werfe diesen Stein, er macht den Parabel, fällt runter. Wenn ich jetzt ein Flugzeug um diesen Stein rumfliegen lasse, der auch so eine Parabel fliegt. Also ich steuere das Flugzeug so, dass er genau um diesen Stein rumfliegt, dann der Stein innerhalb vom Flugzeug ist in einer Situation von Schwerelosigkeit. Er wird nicht zur Decke fliegen, er wird nicht zum Boden fliegen, er wird nicht zu den Dänen fliegen, weil das Flugzeug fliegt drum mit. Das ist bei uns genauso der Fall. Also wir sind im Flugzeug drin und irgendwann fängt das Flugzeug ein Parabel zu fliegen. Und wir fallen alle mit dem Flugzeug mit. Also wir sind in einer Situation vom freien Fall. Das ist eigentlich die Situation von Astronauten in der Erdunlaufbahn auch. Also man sagt öfters, also im Deutschen Gott sei Dank nicht, im Italienisch gibt es diesen falschen Begriff von Gravitationslosigkeit. Das wird öfters gesagt, das ist natürlich nicht der Fall. Die Schwerkraft ist da. Also wir sind jetzt nicht so weit von der Erde. Wir sind in der Raumstation wirklich nur 350 Kilometer von der Erde entfernt. Wenn ich jetzt einen hohen Turm bilden könnte, der genauso hoch ist, 350 Kilometer, und ich bin da oben und ich wiege ungefähr, also wenn ich auf dem Boden 100 kg wiegen würde, dann würde ich dort oben immer noch ungefähr 90 kg wiegen. Also ungefähr 90 Prozent der Schwerkraft ist da. Aber die Raumstation bleibt nicht stehen. Die dreht sich um die Erde mit einer Geschwindigkeit von ungefähr 28 Kilometer pro Stunde, also sieben und ein halber Meter pro Sekunde ungefähr. Das heißt, die würde schon gerne auf die Erde fallen, die dreht aber sich so schnell, dass sie es nicht schafft, auf die Erde zu fallen. Die dreht sich rum die ganze Zeit. Das heißt, die Astronauten sind in einem freien Fall. Und das sind die Leute in einem Parabelflug auch. Aber eben nur ungefähr für 22 Sekunden, weil das Flugzeug kann nur diese Parabel so fliegen. Und dann muss er natürlich außer Parabel raus. Dann nochmal eine, das machen wir ungefähr so 30 Mal.
30 Mal hintereinander.
Wie fühlt man sich da so dabei? Ist das nicht für den Körper eine extreme Belastung?
Also das kann natürlich schwindlig werden und es kann auch den Leuten leicht übel werden. Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, so Spritzen zu bekommen. Das haben wir alle auch getan, weil ich meine, es war Einfluge. Und wir hatten so Übungen zu tun. Also wir konnten das nicht einfach ausprobieren, ob es uns übel geht oder nicht. Spritzen gegen die Übelkeit. Ja, gegen die Übelkeit. Gut, wenn man jetzt viel macht oder so, kann man sich vielleicht überlegen, okay, ich probiere es ohne und schau, was passiert. Aber wir konnten es damals nicht machen.
Und die erste Parabele, war das dann so, wie du das gedacht hast?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hatte keine richtige Vorstellung. Ich meine, es ist schwer, sich zu vorstellen, wie man es sieht, wenn man so frei schwebt. Also es ist wirklich ein Gefühl der Freiheit. Wir sind ein bisschen Kinder wieder geworden. Also nicht nur deswegen, weil es Spaß war, aber auch weil wir Kinder haben wir etwas zum ersten Mal erlebt. Also unseren Körper in einer Situation erlebt, die wir eben zum ersten Mal erlebt haben. Das war ein bisschen so eine Entdeckung, wie das Kinder dann immer machen, die Welt zu entdecken.
Und? Das heißt, man freut sich dann gleich auf die nächste Parabel sozusagen.
Auf jeden Fall, das würden wir gerne alle wieder machen. Es wird auch bestimmt vorkommen, dass wir vielleicht da irgendwelche Experimente unterstützen können, weil wie gesagt, diese Parabelflüge finden regelmäßig statt mit Experimenten von europäischer Wissenschaftler.
Das heißt, man macht sich da auch gleich nützlich. Also man ist da nicht nur jetzt, um da sein kindliches Spiel zu verfolgen. Das sind auch durchaus schon Sachen mit Ergebnis. Also man fällt sozusagen. Ich glaube, Reinhard Ewald hat das im letzten Podcast auch beschrieben. Man fällt die ganze Zeit an der Erde vorbei. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes Bild. Aber das merkt man natürlich nicht. Man ist schon schwerelos, man fliegt die ganze Zeit rum. Das oben und das unten ist irgendwie alles gleich. Der einzige Bezug ist die sichtbare Erde, oder?
Ja, es gibt jetzt nicht so viele Fenster auf der Raumstation. Ich würde mir vorstellen, die meisten Zeit haben die Astronauten keinen Blickkontakt zur Erde. Aber die Raumstation ist schon so ausgelegt, dass man einen virtuellen Boden und eine virtuelle Decke hat. Das heißt, alles ist irgendwie in eine Richtung beschriftet. Die Sachen sind so ausgelegt, dass sie mit den Füßen auf dem Boden betätigt werden.
Um einmal auch so das Gefühl zu geben, dass es eine oben und eine unten gibt.
Ja, weil sonst wär's wirklich verwirrend.
Ja, verstehe. Das ist so, als wenn man sich seine wichtigsten Andenken von zu Hause mitnimmt auf die weite Reise, damit man auch das Gefühl von Heimat hat, wenn es nur oben und unten ist. Ja, haben wir denn jetzt, vielleicht noch mal zusammenzufassen. Also hier im Europäischen Ausbildungszentrum lernt man Kolumbus, man lernt die Kommunikation, auch mit der Bodenstation und es geht auch so weit, dass man selber die Bodenstation sein könnte. Das heißt, die Leute, die Eurocom sind, die mit den Astronauten reden, sind auch selbst immer? Selbst Astronauten?
Nein, das gehört jetzt nicht direkt zur Astronautenausbildung. Aber wenn die Astronauten die Zeit haben, weil sie jetzt nicht unbedingt gleich fliegen müssen und gleich in diese Flugausbildung kommen, dann wird es sehr gut angesehen, dass sie auch als Eurocoms ausgebildet werden. Das gibt den zukünftigen Crew oder Besatzungsmitgliedern die Möglichkeit, die Operationen von Boden zu verfolgen. Zu sehen, wie es ist auf der Seite von der Bodenstation. Weil manchmal ist es vielleicht frustrierend für Astronauten, die an Bord sind und das nicht kennen. Sie stellen vielleicht eine Frage und es dauert auch eine Weile, bis man eine Antwort bekommt. Weil man nicht weiß, was alles auf dem Boden passieren muss, bis man die Antwort hat. Man hat wirklich gesehen, die Astronauten, die das von der Bodenseite kennen, können sich das viel besser vorstellen. Die sind geduldiger, die haben realistischere Erwartungen. Die wissen vielleicht auch, wie man eine Frage am besten stellt, damit man die Antwort am schnellsten bekommt. Es ist immer sehr wichtig, wenn man die Arbeit der anderen Seite auch gut kennt.
Wie kann man das jetzt nicht aussuchen, dass man sagt, ich möchte auch noch mal ein bisschen Eurocom machen vorher?
Das ist hier auf jeden Fall unterstützt. Wenn die Möglichkeit besteht, dann dürfen wir das auf jeden Fall machen. In den USA ist es ein bisschen anders. Das machen nicht unbedingt alle Astronauten, weil sie auch sehr viele sind. Aber es ist auch eine der Möglichkeiten, dass sie haben, so Capcoms als Capcoms zu dienen. Was wir aber auch gemacht haben in der Qantas-Bildung, ist vielleicht die letzten paar Sachen, die ich noch erwähnen möchte, so HBP und Überlebens-Training. Also HBP ist so ein Akronym, da weiß ich sogar, was das heißt. Wir sind ja so mit Akronymen daran gewöhnt, dass wir nicht daran denken.
Ich kann mir das gut vorstellen, dass man das so verinnerlicht, dass man da nicht immer drüber nachdenkt. Das ist ja auch der Sinn von Abkürzung.
Das heißt Human Behavior and Performance. Das sind dann Kurse, die nicht nur von der ESA, sondern auch von NASA und Russland angeboten werden, wo es darum geht, sich mehr Soft-Skills anzueignen. Wie wir das schon erwähnt haben, Teamarbeit, Kommunikation, Konfliktlösungstechniken, Self-Management, Stressabbau. Das Ziel ist wirklich, dass die Menschen als Team eine so gut wie mögliche Leistung erbringen können. Wir haben hier als Teil der Kondusbildung den theoretischen Teil gemacht. Also uns die ganze Theorie angeeignet, wobei es doch auch sehr mit Übungen und so war. Dann wird von ESA so ein Programm angeboten, das heißt The Caves. Das ist noch ein bisschen in der Entwicklungsphase. Im Laufe des Jahres sollte auch die eigentliche Sitzung stattfinden. Und das ist in einem Höhlenforschungs-Szenario. Also die Teilnehmer, die verbringen dann die Zeiten in Höhlen. Und da werden dann Szenarien und Übungen angeboten, wo dann diese HPP-Techniken angewendet werden müssen.
In Höhlen?
Höhlen.
Also wir reden jetzt von so richtig Höhlen im Berg. So Tropfsteinhöhlen?
Ja, Höhlen. Ja, also ich kann jetzt die Details natürlich nicht berichten, weil ich da noch nicht daran teilgenommen habe, aber so wie ich das verstanden habe, ist es so. Man verbringt mehrere Tage diese Höhlen.
Also man lernt sozusagen, so Isolationshaft zu ertragen.
Ja, es geht einfach ein bisschen darum, die Leute in eine Umgebung zu setzen, die unvertraut ist und das vielleicht gewisse Reaktionen hervorbringen kann. Wenn man jetzt in seiner Komfortzone ist die ganze Zeit, dann ist natürlich alles sehr einfach. Aber wenn die Umgebung ein bisschen stressbereitet, unvertraut ist, dann können dann vielleicht gewisse Probleme auftreten und darum geht es ja, diese Probleme zu bewältigen oder das zu üben, wie man solche Probleme bewältigt.
Vor allem schwierige Situationen. Reinhard Ewald hat ja auch von seiner Zeit auf der Mia berichtet und dem Brandt dort ausgetreten ist. Sicherlich ein sehr bekannter Vorfall.
Da kennt man was von schwierigen Situationen.
Inwiefern ist das Teil der Ausbildung, dass man jetzt auch solche Szenarien übt?
Also es ist eben ein bisschen zweiteilig. Diese HBP-Kurse sind dazu ausgerichtet, die psychologischen Seiten ein bisschen zu fordern. Vor allem, wie gesagt, was Zusammenarbeit angeht. Aber die andere Sache ist natürlich, und damit beschäftigt man sich die meiste Zeit, das Vorbereitensein im technischen Sinne. Das heißt, ein Großteil der Ausbildung beschäftigt sich damit, was man in einem Notfall macht. Wir haben jetzt vorhin zum Beispiel vom ATV geredet. Natürlich wird das ATV höchstwahrscheinlich immer problemlos docken, aber in der Ausbildung dockt er nie problemlos. Es werden immer Notfall-Szenarien geübt. Bei der Sojus-Ausbildung ist es genau das Gleiche. Natürlich ist ein normaler Sojus-Start völlig automatisch. Die Crew soll kaum was tun und das Andocken genauso. Aber in der Ausbildung werden alle mögliche Szenarien geübt, wo alles schief geht. Man kann sich nicht da überlegen, was man tun muss.
Was ist der psychologische Anteil dieser Szenarien? Man muss natürlich wissen, wie funktioniert das. Wer hängt das zusammen? Wenn diese Lampe leuchtet, was könnte das bedeuten? Jetzt weiß ich, dass dieses Teil kaputt ist. Welche Gefahr geht davon aus? Etc. Aber was ist sozusagen die wichtige Komponente in der Teamzusammenarbeit? Was ist die Prozedur, die einen quasi vorgibt, in psychologischer Hinsicht zu arbeiten?
Ja, also bin jetzt nicht so die Expertin im Psychologie, muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben. Ich hab immer, auch aus meiner fliegerischen Erfahrung oder so, ich hab immer das Gefühl gehabt, wenn eine Notfallsituation eine schnelle Antwort verlangt, dann ist die technische Vorbereitung schon sehr wichtig, weil man agiert dann automatisch. Also man kümmert sich nicht so sehr um die möglichen Konsequenzen der Situation auf eine psychologische Art und Weise, sondern man agiert einfach automatisch, weil man das tausendmal geübt hat. Ich glaube psychologischen Aspekten, wie gesagt ich bin da keine Expertin, aber vielleicht werden dann wirklich vorrängigen, wenn die Zeit ausgedehnt wird. Also wenn etwas Zeit hat, sich ein bisschen länger abzuspielen, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es wirklich wichtig ist, dass man psychologisch fit ist und dass man auch in der Zusammenarbeit, in der Beziehung zu anderen Menschen...
Das heißt, das kurzfristige Ereignis, das stellt gar nicht so hohe Erforderungen, sondern das ist im Wesentlichen wirklich das technische Vorbereitetsein, dass man einfach weiß, wie es läuft.
Ich könnte es mir vorstellen. Also wie gesagt, ist wahrscheinlich eine Meinungs-Sache.
Bist du denn jetzt auch schon an anderen Ausbildungsorten gewesen?
Ja, also wir waren zwei Monate lang schon im Sternenstädtchen. Und ich habe schon erwähnt, wir haben so ein bisschen eine Einführung in die Soyuz-Simulation. Was wir hauseitlich gemacht haben, ist die Ausbildung auf dem russischen Teil der Raumstation. Für alle Module kann man verschiedene Niveaus von Ausbildung haben. Die nennt man so in der Community User, Operator und Specialist. Also wir haben jetzt die User-Level, also die Benutzerniveausbildung auf dem russischen Teil der Raumstation.
Das heißt, man weiß, wo alles ist?
Man weiß, wo alles ist, man weiß, wie man kommuniziert, also wie man die Interfaces benutzt. Und vor allem weiß man, was man im Notfall machen muss. Also User-Level ist wirklich, da geht es wirklich hauptsächlich darum, die Notfallausrüstung benutzten zu können. Also für Feuer zum Beispiel oder Druckausfall.
Und für den europäischen Teil bist du dann schon eher auf dem Operator-Level?
Genau, für Columbus haben wir schon Operator-Level. Und bei der NASA haben wir bis jetzt nur wirklich eine kurze Einführung gehabt. Also das kommt alles noch.
Das heißt, ein Besuch in Houston steht auf jeden Fall an?
Genau, wir waren da, wir waren eine Woche da und eine Woche in Japan und wir haben so ein bisschen eine Einführung sowohl auf dem amerikanischen Teil als auch auf dem japanischen Teil, also das Labor der Japaner gehabt, aber ohne jetzt eine formelle Ausbildungsabschluss.
Also es geht erstmal darum, zu sehen, die gibt es auch. Ja, dass man sich überhaupt erstmal eine Vorstellung macht von den Realitäten vor Ort, von den Leuten.
Ganz genau, das war es.
Aber japanisch muss man nicht lernen?
Nein, japanisch muss man nicht lernen.
Sondern im Japanen kommuniziert man dann auch auf Englisch? Was steht denn dann sozusagen als nächstes an? Also wenn man jetzt diese Grundausbildung hat, dann ist es jetzt quasi ein Warten auf ein Assignment. Also ist jetzt schon die Phase angetreten, wo man eigentlich so ein bisschen Leerlauf hat und nur weiter vertieft und das regelmäßig tun muss, was man machen muss zum körperlichen Fitness?
Also sagen wir so, das Astronautenleben in dieser Wartezeit ist ein bisschen zweigeteilt. Also auf einer Seite geht das Training weiter, aber wie gesagt nicht Vollzeit, weil das vielleicht noch ein bisschen auf sich warten lässt, das eigentliche Flug. Auf der anderen Seite muss man Aufgaben übernehmen, die sinnvoll sind innerhalb der ESA. Und eine Möglichkeit haben wir schon erwähnt, das ist das Eurocom, das machen schon zwei Kollegen von mir. Man kann dann sonst Projekte unterstützen, auf Reviews teilnehmen. Das ist da immer sehr begrüßt, wenn zum Beispiel ein neues Experiment entwickelt wird, da werden natürlich Prozeduren geschrieben, Sicherheitsprotokolle und so weiter. Und irgendwann müssen sich alle Teilnehmer zusammensetzen und das nochmal überprüfen und sagen, ok, das ist ein Review. Und es ist normalerweise immer so, dass ein Astronaut teilnimmt, um eine Perspektive der Astronauten oder der Benutzer dieser Geräte oder dieser Experimente mitbringt. Das kann man machen. Oder einfach an irgendwelchen Entwicklungsprojekten mit teilzunehmen. Ein Kollege von uns unterstützte die mögliche Entwicklung von dem ATV, das ist das ARV, also das Advanced Reentry Vehicle. Das wäre dann eine mögliche Entwicklung vom ATV im Sinne von Wiedereintrittsfähigkeit. Also im Moment, das ATV kann nicht gesund zur Erde wieder kommen, sondern es verbrennt in der Atmosphäre. Und eine mögliche Weiterentwicklung wäre es eben dem ATV eine Möglichkeit zu geben, teilweise zumindest gesund den Wiedereintritt zu überleben.
Das ist noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik.
Es hat schon Studien gegeben, aber noch auf Papierform. Aber es ist eine Möglichkeit für die Zukunft.
Und womit ist jetzt zu rechnen? Mit welchem Assignment? Gibt es da schon eine Mission, die sich abzeichnet? Also im Wesentlichen geht es ja um Langzeitaufenthalt.
Wir sechs neue Astronauten sind hier für diese sechs Monate Einsätze auf die Raumstation ausgewählt und ausgebildet worden. Ich habe schon erwähnt, ein Kollege fliegt schon in 2013 zur Raumstation. In 2014 gibt es noch einmal eine ESA-Fluke. In 2015 gibt es eine Flüge der Italienischen Anfahrtagentur. Das heißt, man muss einfach ein bisschen warten und jeder wird dann seine Chance bekommen, in den Weltraum zu fliegen.
Was hast du denn jetzt außer der Fähigkeit, sich an einer Raumstation aufzuhalten, noch aus dieser Grundausbildung herausgezogen? Also wenn ich mir das so anhöre, dann ist das ja schon wirklich eine extreme Bandbreite. Also es ist eine extreme Bandbreite in wissenschaftlicher Hinsicht, in psychologischer Hinsicht, bzw. diese Teamfähigkeit scheint ja wirklich eine enorme Bedeutung zu haben, ist ja auch nachvollziehbar. Also das zu lernen mit allen, sowohl mit den Leuten vor Ort, also dann in der Raumstation zu kommunizieren, eben als auch mit der Bodenstation. Das versetzt einen ja sicherlich auch in die Lage, das gesamte Geschehen der Raumfahrt. Man beobachtet es ja einfach anders. Man verfolgt dann alle Missionen. Was hast du zu diesem Zeitpunkt da für dich schon selbst gewonnen und herausgezogen und wie hat das den Blick auf die Raumfahrt für dich geändert?
Na, erstens muss ich sagen, vielleicht bin ich mir jetzt mehr bewusst, dass ich es vor zwei Jahren war, wie viel ich nicht weiß von der Raumfahrt. Das heißt, wenn man das von außen beobachtet, weiß man eigentlich nicht, oder vielleicht hat man ein Gefühl. Aber es ist mir mehr und mehr bewusst worden, wie kompliziert das alles ist. Wie viel Wissen man sich aneignen muss. Und wie viel Wissen man sich nicht aneignen kann. Man muss irgendwie irgendwo darauf verzichten, irgendwie alles zu wissen, weil das ist einfach zu viel. Das heißt, man muss sich einfach darauf verlassen, dass die Leute ihren Job tun, ohne dass man da einen Einblick hat, weil alles kann man nicht können, alles kann man nicht wissen, alles kann man nicht überwachen. Das heißt, ein bisschen als Astronaut muss man wirklich lernen, da Entscheidungen zu treffen, wo man sich konzentriert, was man wirklich wissen möchte. Da hilft natürlich die Training-Community, weil es wird uns normalerweise auch wirklich nur das beigebracht, was man wissen muss. Aber wir müssen dann auch akzeptieren, dass noch alles Mögliche sich hinläuft, dass wir nicht wissen, dass wir nicht verstehen. Wir müssen einfach mal Vertrauen haben. Das ist, glaube ich, in der Raumfahrt... Das war jetzt in meinem früheren Leben als Luftwaffenpiloten auch so natürlich. Man muss sich darauf verlassen, dass die Mechaniker ihr Job tun. Ich kann das jetzt nicht alles überprüfen. Aber hier ist es noch mehr so, weil es ist noch komplexer. Es sind noch mehr Leute damit beschäftigt. Manchmal hat man wirklich das Gefühl, man weiß so wenig. Man ist diejenigen, die da hochfliegen. Aber eigentlich weiß man so wenig, weil so viel läuft, so viele Leute damit beschäftigt sind. Es ist auch das Tolle daran, finde ich. Man hat wirklich das Gefühl, dass da sehr viele Menschen mit großem Einsatz, mit großen Fähigkeiten, mit großer Leidenschaft sich dabei was beitragen. Das ist fast eine Magie, dass diese ganze Arbeit irgendwie so koordiniert ist, dass dann so was Tolles wie die Raumstation und die tägliche Arbeit auf der Raumstation da rauskommt. Da hab ich da ein bisschen schon mit Perspektive geändert.
Das heißt, man lernt auch zu akzeptieren, dass man nicht alles weiß. Und man braucht aber dann auch im Umkehrschluss ein enormes Vertrauen eigentlich. Man weiß ja, das eigene Leben hängt förmlich noch nicht mal an einem dünnen Seil. Man fällt eigentlich die ganze Zeit auf die Erde, bloß vorbei. Man gibt sich ja da auch in die Hände von anderen.
Auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall. Und auch in der Ansbildung, man darf jetzt nicht, man muss natürlich kritisch sein, aber man muss schon, die Grundeinstellung sollte schon sein, höchstwahrscheinlich ist das der beste Weg oder die beste Lösung. Weil wenn man jetzt wirklich kritisch alles nachfragt, das wäre unmöglich, einen Astronauten zu trainieren in der Zeit. Irgendwann muss man die richtige Balance finden, zwischen natürlich kritisch sein und womöglich auch konstruktiv, aber auch einfach mal darauf vertrauen, dass die Leute die beste Lösung gefunden haben und einfach die lernen und einsetzen. Der Astronaut, man möchte von einem Astronauten nicht unbedingt, dass sie kreativ neue Lösungen finden, sondern dass sie das, was denen beigebracht wurde, so gut wie möglich und hoffentlich fehlerlos machen. Fehler machen wir alle die ganze Zeit, aber das Ziel ist natürlich, so wenig Fehler wie möglich zu machen.
ZB auch so fehlertolerant wie möglich vorgehen zu können.
Genau.
Jetzt entwickelt sich die Technik auch rasant weiter. In der Raumfahrt braucht Technik natürlich immer eine Weile, bis sie von brand new zu gut abgehangen und zuverlässig kommt. Trotzdem dürfte ja auch über diesen gesamten Zeitraum, den man sich in der Ausbildung findet, auch die Technik sich weiterentwickeln. Inwiefern muss man dieses Wissen, was man so hat, permanent aktualisieren? Oder trägt man selber sogar dazu bei?
Teilweise trägt man dazu bei natürlich. Wenn man an irgendwelche Projekte teilnimmt, dann erlebt man das wirklich live, wie sich das weiterentwickelt. Aber ansonsten, man kann schon darauf vertrauen, dass, wenn man dann zu einer Besatzung zugeteilt wird, in der Ausbildung zum Flug dann wirklich den letzten Stand der Dinge auch erfährt. Da würde ich mir keine Sorgen machen.
Jetzt haben wir viel über das eigentliche Astronautenhandwerk geredet. Was aber auch eine wichtige Rolle spielt, was man ja auch schnell vergisst. In dem Moment, wo man jetzt im Einsatz ist, man ist vor Ort in der ISS, man ist im Kolumbus, dann ist man im Wesentlichen mit den wissenschaftlichen Experimenten beschäftigt. Man ist auch selber ein wissenschaftliches Experiment. Da hängen ja viele Kabel an einem dran. Man ist ja auch so ein bisschen, weiß nicht, man könnte sich ja schon fast so ein bisschen ferngesteuert vorkommen. Man ist ferngesteuert tatsächlich. Ich erinnere mich jetzt noch in der Sendung, wo wir hier vor allem über Operations geredet haben, wo eben insbesondere bei diesen Fernmissionen, wo sich permanent immer wieder neue Gelegenheiten ergeben, wo vor allem diese Zusammenarbeit mit den Wissenschaftlern eine große Rolle spielt. Also denen, die jetzt nicht selber mit hochfliegen, sondern die einfach diese eigentlichen Experimente vorbereiten und die natürlich auch eine enorme Erwartung an die Ergebnisse haben. Nicht nur, weil es irgendwie teuer ist und man nicht so viele Gelegenheiten hat, das zu tun, sondern weil man natürlich da auch was vorkommen muss. Inwiefern lernt man denn, also inwiefern ist man überhaupt mit diesen Wissenschaftlern direkt im Kontakt? Also wie funktioniert das jetzt, sich so konkret auf so eine wissenschaftliche Mission auch vorzubereiten? Welche Aspekte kommen da noch mit rein?
Also eine direkte Erfahrung damit habe ich nicht. Sobald ich das verstehe, und ich könnte das durchaus nicht voll verstehen, werden Astronauten hauptsächlich von Trainern ausgebildet. Das sind dann Menschen, also zum Beispiel im Fall von europäischen Experimenten hier am ERC, die sich mit dem Experiment beschäftigt haben und die ein Training für die Astronauten entwickelt haben. Also die haben dann wirklich so Unterrichter entwickelt, in denen sie dann den Inhalt den Astronauten so effizient wie möglich beibringen möchten. Ich weiß, dass teilweise die Astronauten auch direkt in diesen User Support Centers ausgebildet werden. Das sind dann die kleine Control Centers, die dann über Columbus Control Centers direkt für die Bodenunterstützung von Experimenten verantwortlich sind. Wir haben zum Beispiel hier auf dem DLR-Gelände einen gegenüber. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass die Astronauten immer einen direkten Kontakt zum Wissenschaftler haben. Wobei ich der Meinung bin, dass sich die Situation in der Richtung entwickelt, mehr und mehr. Ich persönlich würde mich natürlich freuen, wenn ich jetzt ein Experiment auf der Raumschätzung betreibe, würde ich mich persönlich sehr freuen, den Wissenschaftlern kennenzulernen. Und wenn möglich auch, wenn ich da oben bin, dann einen direkten Kontakt zu haben. Wie gesagt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, dass es jetzt der Fall ist. Aber ich glaube, die Entwicklung geht in die Richtung.
Warum geht die Entwicklung in die Richtung?
Ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen Feedback gehört von Astronauten, die sagen, sie würden sich eigentlich freuen, direkt mit einem Wissenschaftler zu tun zu haben. Das ist ein bisschen mehr ein direkter Kontakt mit den Menschen, die das entwickelt haben. Ich glaube, das funktioniert ganz gut.
Das heißt, man wird auch selber eigentlich zum Forscher da oben?
Ein bisschen. Also wie gesagt, es sind nicht die Astronauten, die das entwickelt haben. Es sind wahrscheinlich öfters auch nicht diejenigen, die den perfekten Einblick haben in die Materie. Man ist ja nicht Experten in allen möglichen Bereichen. Das können wir nicht sein. Aber ich glaube, wir fühlen alle schon die Verantwortung, das so gut wie möglich zu machen. Wir verstehen schon, dass da Erwartungen sind von Leuten, die jahrelang darauf gewartet haben, da ihre Ergebnisse zu haben. Die Verantwortung spürt man, glaube ich.
Wenn man die anderen Astronauten kennenlernt, es gibt jetzt hier sechs, die gerade in der Ausbildung befinden, sind nur jetzt als europäische Astronauten. Aber es gibt ja genauso dann auch noch in Japan und Russland. Wie viele Astronauten sind das so ungefähr, die sich derzeit so vorbereiten auf eine mögliche Mission?
Also in Europa sind wir noch nicht nur sechs. Ich habe immer noch von sechs geredet, weil ich mich eben ein bisschen mehr auf meine Grundausbildung bezogen habe. Aber wir haben natürlich auch ältere Astronauten. Wie gesagt, Paulo Nespol ist auf der Raumstation jetzt. Der andere Kuiper fliegt demnächst. Das heißt, der fliegt immer wieder zwischen Sternenstädtchen und Houston und manchmal hier für seine Flugausbildung. Roberto Vittori ist in Houston. Da fliegt er demnächst auf dem Shuttle. Das ist noch der letzte, der so einen Kurzzeitflug machen darf. Und wir haben noch, sagen wir mal, nicht so junge, nicht ganz mehr so junge wie wir, Astronauten, die sich jetzt nicht gerade auf einen Flug vorbereiten, sondern andere Tätigkeiten übernommen haben. Zum Beispiel Frau Sauquervois, Leopold Ehrens, Hans Schlegel.
Das heißt, man befindet sich dann auch so schnell in so einer Astronauten-Community und sicherlich auch nochmal so ein ganz eigener Wahrnehmungsbereich, den diese Community für sich hat. Aber was mich interessiert hat, ist der Kontakt mit den anderen Astronauten außerhalb der europäischen Gruppe. Da gab es sicherlich jetzt auch schon Begegnungen, oder?
Ja, wie gesagt, es gibt immer wieder welche, die hier kommen zur Ausbildung. Und als wir dann in Sternenstädtchen waren, haben wir natürlich vor allem sehr viel Zeit mit den NASA-Astronauten verbracht, die dort in der Ausbildung sind.
Und was stellt man da fest? Gibt es da große Unterschiede? Oder ist es gerade so, dass man sich in einem so internationalen Projekt bewegt, dass die Unterschiede gar nicht mehr ins Gewicht fahren?
Ich glaube, dass einfach dieses Astronautensein, so eine besondere Erfahrung ist, das das einfach verbindet. Wir haben das vor allem im Sternenstädtchen erwähnt, erlebt, es bildet sich wirklich so ein Community-Gefühl, ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl. Man fühlt sich, obwohl man sich kaum kennt, aber man hat sofort das Gefühl, dass man Freunde ist, oder dass man sich aufeinander verlassen kann, dass man miteinander reden kann. Klar, es gibt Unterschiede, wir sind alle Menschen, wir sind alle unterschiedlich, aber im Allgemeinen gibt es schon ein ziemlich starkes Community-Gefühl, trotz den verschiedenen Nationalitäten und so weiter. Und klar, die Astronauten-Community ist sehr international geprägt, vor allem in Europa. Wir sind sehr international ausgerichtet.
Ich glaube, internationaler geht es auch fast gar nicht mehr.
Genau. Unser DG, unser Direktor General, der sagt immer, wir sind die Weltmeister von Kooperationen. Da können wir schon vielleicht der Welt was beibringen.
Ja, haben wir denn jetzt noch irgendeinen wichtigen Aspekt vergessen, den man vielleicht besser noch erwähnen sollte, um das Bild der Astronautenausbildung abzuschließen?
Vielleicht kurz zur Grundausbildung haben wir vielleicht noch das Überlebens-Training nicht erwähnt. Das gehört auch zur Astronautenausbildung. Bei uns in der Grundausbildung ging es um einen Einführungskurs, also einen sehr allgemeinen Überlebens-Training. Aber was noch kommt, ist ein Soyuz-bezogenes Überlebens-Training, zwar zweigeteilt. Also es gibt Überlebens-Training im See und Überlebens-Training im Winter. Weil im Unterschied zum Space Shuttle, der ja immer auf einer Landebahn landen muss oder gar nicht landet, der Soyuz ist ja eine Kapsel. Und es könnte sein, dass sie nicht ganz genau dorthin landet, wo sie landen musste. Oder es könnte sein, dass einfach die Wetterbedingungen so schlecht sind, dass die Rettungskräfte nicht gleich dahin kommen. Und deswegen verlangt man von den Astronauten und Kosmonauten, dass sie eine gewisse Zeit auch selbstständig überleben können. Es gibt in der Kapsel eine Überlebensausrüstung. Und dann in diesen speziellen Überlebenskurse lernt man, wie man mit dieser Soyuz-Ausrüstung umgeht. Und wie gesagt, in einer Winterumgebung, das macht man normalerweise in Russland im Januar, und in einer Seeumgebung, und das wird normalerweise im Schwarzen Meer im Sommer gemacht.
Das heißt im See, das ist wirklich für den Fall, dass die Kapsel in so ein See reinfällt?
Ganz genau, ja. Und das ist, glaube ich, nur einmal passiert, aber es kann durchaus vorkommen. Und dann muss man in der kleinen Kapsel, also die Soyuz ist dann wirklich sehr klein. Also in Italien sage ich immer, sie ist ein bisschen wie eine Fiat Cinquecento. Ich weiß nicht, ob das in Deutschen auch in Begriff ist. Man ist zu dritt da drin und man hat so einen sehr großen Anzug an. Und im Fall einer Seelandung muss man aus diesem Anzug irgendwie zu dritt dann rauskommen, in den Seeüberlebensanzug rein und dann aus der Kapsel raus.
Achso, es gibt einen speziellen Anzug nur für den Fall, dass man im See landet.
Genau. Und es ist nicht ganz so einfach da aus dem normalen Anzug rauszukommen, diesen Anzug anzutun. Und es gibt so einen kleinen, einen von diesen aufblasbaren Rettungsboten und das muss man alles dann üben.
Also jeder, der sich schon mal in einem Fiat 500 umgezogen hat, kann das nachvollziehen. Das ist auch das, was mich immer wieder umhaut. So sehr man auch versucht, das aus der Ferne alles vorzustellen, das sind dann immer vor allem diese ganzen Möglichkeiten und Eventualitäten, die so mit reinkommen, die man so erstmal überhaupt nicht bedenkt, aber die natürlich am Ende wirklich auch überlebenswichtig sind.
Klar.
Was ist, wenn man im See landet? Das kann ja ganz schön tief sein. Aber das muss man sozusagen selber aussteigen, also irgendwie warten, bis man hochgezogen wird. Und im Winter muss man dann?
Ja, im Winter muss man da auch aus der Kassel raus, natürlich. Und versuchen, irgendwas zu bauen, um sich warm zu halten und sich vor allem von der Kälte zu schützen. Iglu? Ja, Iglu. Die Syriese landet mit einem Fallschirm. Das heißt, man kann den Fallschirm ein bisschen benutzen, um dazu helfen, ein bisschen Isolierung der Isolierung ein bisschen beizutragen. Und ansonsten werde ich das alles noch lernen.
Ja, Samantha, vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es erstmal auch wieder eine Menge gelernt. Also auch ich bin hier voll in der Grundausbildung angekommen eigentlich. Ich habe es schon angedeutet, wir werden dem Astronauten-Thema hier auch noch eine Weile treu bleiben. Hier bei Raumzeit. Wie wir überhaupt dem ganzen Raumfahrt-Thema hier natürlich treu bleiben. Es gibt da noch so einiges zu berichten. Aber für heute ist jetzt erstmal Schluss. Nochmal vielen Dank. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und bis bald, bis zur nächsten Ausgabe von Raumzeit.